[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY ARDEN: Hi, I'm Jenny.
I'm a designer at Google.
I work on the
self-driving car project.
Before this project at Google,
I worked on YouTube for TV,
designing TV-specific
experiences.
And I also worked on Google's
core business search.
So before that, I had my
fair share of agency work,
mostly in New York City.
And I've started a couple
small businesses as well.
So what I want to
talk about today
is what it feels like to be
a creative person working
on a project that has
no concrete definition
and has very little structure.
More specifically, I want to
talk about the emotional ups
and downs that creative-minded
people go through when they're
working on something
brand new, and how
you can use those emotions
to be your North Star.
So to start out, I want you
to think back and recollect
the first moment that you
had a truly creative moment
and recognized it.
For some of you, it may
have been a simple drawing.
And I think there are some
rock stars in this room
probably had been
artistic since birth,
so this shouldn't
be too hard for you.
So this is mine.
I drew this when I was three.
And it hangs in the kitchen
of my house where I grew up.
My mom looks at it
every single day
when she makes
her cup of coffee.
What I love about
this is it somehow
captured life according
to my three-year-old eyes.
You have my parents.
My mom's on the right.
She's kind of leaning back.
My dad's in the middle.
Then we have our old sofa.
We had this thing forever.
And I used to play
with my toys on it.
And then on the left, in
a very abstracted way,
is a huge pile of books.
And we had piles and piles
of books in our house.
What I like about this is that
somehow, this simple drawing,
it accurately
represented everything
that I had at that time.
So for other people, their
first creative experience
may have been building a fort.
My mom is a
self-employed writer.
So we used to get these
really insanely thick boxes
full of her books.
And they were the ultimate
building material for kids.
So we would create these very
elaborate mazes and forts.
And sometimes, especially
in our own bedrooms,
we would layer them,
kind of creating a three,
four-story maze.
And they were kind of
like a human ant farm.
So what we loved about
building these forts
is that we made
something out of nothing.
Somehow you can take something
as clean as cardboard
and make it interesting
and important.
In this picture, this is an
architecture firm that I found.
They're called Nothing.
And their entire premise
is based off the idea
that you can take something
very simple, a plot of land,
something that
has nothing there,
and make something absolutely
beautiful out of it.
Their office, the
interior of their office,
is built entirely
out of cardboard,
and it's pretty elaborate.
So despite all this creativity
that we have at an early age,
something happens.
Kids are fearless and
will show their art.
But as we get older, we're
less secure with our confidence
and our own creativity.
The door starts to
close, and many designers
keep their work locked away
until they think it's perfect,
or until they have a
deadline and they're
forced to show it to their team.
We start to fear judgment.
We fear judgment from
our peers, and we
fear that we're going
to be embarrassed.
How many times have you looked
over a designer's shoulder
to see their work in progress,
and their actual posture
starts to change?
They start to recoil, and their
voice sounds apprehensive.
And they give you
this doe-eyed look
that they just fear
that you're going
to say it's going to suck.
That is their worst nightmare.
So why is this?
Part of our DNA, the fact
that we are designers,
we have built into our
DNA the essence of taste.
Being a great designer
is to have good taste
and to know what good
taste looks like.
This means we love beauty,
and invention, and things
that surprise us.
We fall in love
with great design.
But we also want to
produce that great design
and have an effect
on other people.
But as we face this
big blank page,
whether that's your
sketch book or Photoshop
or whatever tool you use,
and start to design away,
our craft doesn't
always meet our taste.
And it's especially
in the beginning
of a designer's career
this is very true.
So sometimes our
fear of judgment
is actually knowing for a fact
that the design we've created
is not nearly as good
as we want it to be,
and we're about to
be called out on it.
So let's layer on top of
that those moments when
you work on a project
that's truly innovative.
I've been working on the
self-driving car, which
is pretty innovative, so I've
been living and breathing
this uncharted territory
for quite a while.
Now you're this designer
that wants to create,
and you're swimming
in this abyss.
You're in this space
of uncertainty.
You want to grab at all
the tangible aspects
and make something out of it.
And you don't have
all the answers yet.
So in the back of
your head, you know
that you want to make
something great as a designer.
You're working with
a project that you
don't have all the
definitions for.
And you want to make it awesome.
So what does this mean?
For those that can
relate, definitely
the entrepreneurs and
inventors in this room,
you know that being in this
spot can be a very lonely place.
It's especially
interesting when you're
surrounded by nondesigners,
and they're all looking at you
to come up with a solution
because you're the creative.
For your coworkers that haven't
been on a project like this
before, they make the
project look like this.
And they may think
it looks like this,
where it has a
beginning and an end.
The reality?
Experience is a lot like this.
For those who are confused,
this is Tough Mudder.
This race is full of
obstacles, and scary hazards,
and barbed wire,
and contraptions
that will electrocute you.
It's pretty crazy,
and people pay for it.
It's messy, and it's
ugly, and you're not
sure you're going to finish.
So what's interesting is that
it's less about the individual,
and it's more about
the team effort.
Everyone has to help
everyone to finish.
I can say for a fact that I've
been on three projects that
have definitely felt like this.
And I'm going to walk you
through two of them today.
Several years ago, when I
was working in New York City,
I was working with an
agency called Razorfish.
You might have heard of it.
And this is a project
that was really
based on business innovation.
So a small team
of us were tasked
with creating a really
interesting dashboard
for the United Nations.
This project was
focused specifically
on economic
development in Africa.
For 12 years,
representatives from the UN
went door to door
to small businesses
throughout the continent
and interviewed the owners.
They would ask questions
like, was tax rate reasonable?
Did you have to use a
bribe to get business done?
Were you able to find
educated workers?
Did you have reliable
access to electricity
and water-- some pretty
basic things to do business.
So hundreds and hundreds of
questions-- again, 12 years.
They had this massive database,
this huge spreadsheet.
And all the answers
were collected verbally
and then compiled into this
database, mostly a huge Excel
spreadsheet.
And this was a lot of work.
I mean, 12 years
is a lot of work.
So why did they do this?
They had a vision.
And they thought if they
can collect this data,
they can reveal to
foreign investors
which countries were
doing fair business
and which countries were
actually very corrupt.
This was a very important time.
Many large companies
were looking at Africa
as the next big emerging market.
The cost of business
in India and China,
it was already rising.
So Africa was seen as the next
step for companies seeking
alternative low-cost solutions.
This dashboard that we
created, this was a prototype.
This was just a rough design.
It really represented
the parsing of the data
and allowed for quick
custom filtering,
display visualization,
and revealed
the countries that were
doing fair business
and the countries that
had corrupt practices
in a real and tangible way.
They could actually see it.
So three months later, to my
surprise, I am now in Ethiopia.
And I have to present this.
Never been to the continent of
Africa, definitely never been
to Ethiopia-- very cool
place, very vibrant,
full of color and life.
And I found myself
presenting these designs
to diplomats, and ministers,
and African leaders seated
in a very traditional UN setup.
If you've ever seen
pictures of it or on TV,
it feels very official.
Each person sits at their desk.
They have their placard.
They have their translator
with a microphone.
They have titles like
Kenyan Minister of Mines,
which I did not know existed.
And all of these diplomats
were there to listen to us
and to see our solution.
To be honest, I was
absolutely terrified.
There was not a single
designer in that room.
And they were all
definitely official looking.
But what helped us
more than anything
was believing that the actual
solution that we'd created
solved the problem.
But what was also scary
was that the solution
was incredibly polarizing.
So we gave this
presentation, and we
get two types of feedback.
Naturally, those
representatives from
business-friendly
countries were psyched.
We're now finally rewarding
them for doing good business.
But those other
countries, those countries
that maybe had not
so favorable scores,
they were pretty
pissed off at us.
And that was a
difficult situation
to be in when you're
trying to present that.
So the takeaway from
that is that when
you're working on something
that can fundamentally
change how we
think of a problem,
it's very likely that you're
going to make a lot of friends.
But you can also
make some enemies,
and you'll have some naysayers.
I think Airbnb and Uber probably
experienced some of this.
They kind of know what
we're talking about.
And the self-driving car, we
deal with some of this as well.
The design may not have
been revolutionary.
Data dashboards are not special.
But the use of that
design had a huge impact.
In this case, we
were potentially
affecting the business landscape
of an entire continent, which
is a huge thing.
Now let's talk about
the self-driving car.
This is the next
project that I'd
say I was in kind of a
Tough Mudder situation.
On this project, I'm
reminded every single day
that we're solving a
computer science problem.
Now mind you, when I
came onto the project,
I had no automotive
background whatsoever.
I am a user experience designer.
I try to actually get to the
heart of what people really
want.
So as a designer,
I'm reminded why
we're doing this
in the first place.
I'm motivated by how
the project can actually
change lives, and communities,
and landscapes in a real way.
I'm motivated by the idea
that we are all bad drivers
if we want to admit it or not.
We text.
We read emails.
I've seen people put
makeup on while driving.
I saw a guy eating a bowl
of soup while driving.
This is actually truly
dangerous, life-threatening
behavior that we are conducting.
And we just do it because
it's always that chance
that it's not me.
I'm not the one that's
going to cause the problem.
So diving a bit deeper
into the project,
we can talk about the lasers,
and the radars, and the map
tiles, and the latency.
But what my team, the
UX team, is really doing
is creating experience
that does not yet exist.
What's really interesting
is that we've actually
been talking about self-driving
cars since the '50s.
This illustration was
created in the '50s.
So it's not really
a new concept.
But what is happening
now is that we're now
creating the first
experience for it.
It's not just blue-sky reality.
It's now an actual experience.
So we have a lot of questions.
First off, where do we start?
If there's no analogous
offering out there,
how do you start
creating experience?
And then the next big question
is, what is the new driving?
If you're not driving,
what is driving then?
We're going to show you a video.
And this was produced by
the self-driving car team
to show you what the experience
of the prototype feels like
and how people reacted to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Today we have
something extra special
for you guys.
And you guys will be
some of the first people
outside of our team and outside
of Google to ever ride in it.
JANET: Ah, there it is.
ALL: Wow!
LINDA: Isn't that cute?
MALE SPEAKER: Go
ahead and buckle up.
JUDY: OK, Annie, here we go.
ANNIE: Here we go.
THIDA: All right,
Connie, let's go.
LINDA: There's no
steering wheel in the way.
CHRIS URMSON: It was
a big decision for us
to go and start building
our purpose-built vehicles
for this.
And really, they're
prototype vehicles.
They were a chance for us to
explore, what does it really
mean to have a
self-driving vehicle?
But in the small amount of
time we've been working on it,
we have functional prototypes.
It's exciting.
THIDA: It's really cool.
It was really kind of
a space-age experience.
JUDY: Oh, OK!
Hurray!
We're like queens.
ANNIE: You sit, relax.
You don't have to do nothing.
It knows when you need to stop.
It knows when you need to go.
JUDY: It actually rides
better than my own car.
ANNIE: Yes.
It's true.
WALT: What she really liked
was that it slowed down
before it went around a
curve and then accelerated--
WALT AND LINDA: --in the curve.
WALT: She's always trying
to get me to do it that way.
LINDA: That's the way I learned
in high school driver's ed.
JANET: So if I had
a self-driving car,
I could spend more time
hanging out with my kids,
or helping them
with their homework,
even just tending
to them, finding out
how their day was,
and not having
to wait until you get home
and have dinner and all that.
So it would be good.
NICK: Human feeling of it
is very well engineered.
And it is very smooth.
There's nothing that makes you
feel the least bit threatened.
It's impressive.
I'm totally in love with this
whole concept. [LAUGHTER]
STEVE: Our lives are made up of
lots and lots of little things.
And a lot of those little
things for most people
have to do with getting
from place to place,
in order to connect and
do things, be with people,
go places that they need
to go, and do things.
And so there's a big part
of my life that's missing.
And there is a big
part of my life
that a self-driving vehicle
would bring back to me.
CHRIS URMSON: This is
a first step for us.
And it's really exciting to
see the progress we've made.
The opportunity for people
to just move around and not
worry about it-- it's going
to be incredibly empowering
and incredibly
powerful for people.
STEVE: I love this!
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JENNY ARDEN: Great,
so you kind of
get to see a little bit
of what it feels like.
A lot of people, when they
first think about self-driving,
they're worried about
giving up control.
And they're thinking that
it's going to be really scary.
But it ends up actually being
pretty boring after 30 seconds.
You're just kind of sitting
back, and you let it go.
So you've all seen our Lexus
vehicles driving around.
And we've learned a lot
from those vehicles.
And we're still
learning from them.
They're still driving
around, and we're still
improving our software.
At some point, Chris Urmson,
who you saw in that video,
decided it was time to really
create our own vehicle that's
entirely focused
on self-driving.
The industrial design
team did an amazing job
creating a car that's truly
optimized for the sensors
and cameras.
That's why we did this.
So it may look
cute and friendly.
But it's also
designed with purpose.
Every choice there
had a purpose.
You saw in the video that
there's no steering wheel.
There are no peddles.
There's no control.
And that changes the entire
experience in a vehicle.
So what you're seeing here,
now getting into the software,
this is the
engineering interface
that we have that displays
what the vehicle's seeing.
And it's definitely an
engineering interface.
When you're in the
prototype vehicle
and you're looking at
this at the same time,
it's pretty fascinating.
And this display's
changing real time.
And in this particular
design, you are the red car.
So that's the actual vehicle.
You have other cars around you.
Those are the purple boxes.
And this is a pretty
interesting situation,
because a group of pedestrians
is crossing the crosswalk,
and you're trying to turn right.
So you see the trajectory of
a green line to the right.
And the yellow boxes
there are pedestrians.
So we're really
tracking everything
that we see, all the
different objects.
We can categorize what
kind of object it is.
Is it a car?
Is it a bike?
Is it a pedestrian?
And we can predict a little bit
of what they're going to do.
So we kind of know
where pedestrians walk.
We kind of know where cars go.
But we also are constantly
collecting more data
in case something
happens and we need
to make an emergency maneuver.
We believe that this
interface is pretty important
as far as user experience goes.
And it helps the
user learn to be
comfortable with
giving up control.
As we work on a more
consumer-facing version
of this, we're asking
ourselves a lot of questions.
So how much do we show?
This is showing
everything that we know.
It's pretty detailed,
which may not be necessary.
Maybe people don't
need to see all this.
So do we show
everything or we don't?
Should we do an
edited-down version?
Should it be super realistic, or
should it be super abstracted?
That's another thing
that we're trying
to figure out as
a design problem.
And then what about
camera angles?
We can actually do almost any
camera angle in this display.
So here we're kind of
bird's eye from the back.
But we could do true birds eye.
We can pan right.
We can pan left.
We could do first person, as
if you're just looking out
through the window as
if you're a driver.
So we have a lot of variables
here, and a lot of things
that we have to test over
and over and over again.
So lots of questions--
absolutely no
precedents for this.
We're trying our best guesses.
This is our process.
We try our best guesses.
We prototype every day.
We're prototyping
and prototyping.
And we're refining
over and over again.
Frankly, it's a
really long process
with lots of uncertainty.
And as we chip away at it,
we get closer and closer
to something that we believe in.
So the software engineers
and the digital designers
on this project, as opposed
to the industrial designers,
we have a unique challenge.
So for one, the prototype
is almost entirely
controlled through a phone app.
It's literally the
keys to your car.
So there are not a lot
of phone apps out there
that have that level
of mission-critical
responsibility.
The only experience I can think
of that comes close to this
is when you use an
electronic boarding pass
when you go to the airport.
If your phone dies, you're
not getting on that plane.
But you do have another option.
You can hassle the gate agent
to print you another one.
You wait in that line.
They're usually pretty busy.
So it's kind of a hassle,
but it's not a huge deal.
So it's not quite an
analogy, but it's close.
We're also working
hard at creating trust.
I think a lot of
new technologies
have this challenge.
But seeing that this
is a moving vehicle,
it's even more important
to let the user know
what the car knows.
So that was the
self-driving car.
If you have questions,
definitely I
can answer some of them.
A lot of the things
related to the program,
I can't really answer
those questions, especially
our detailed process.
People always try to ask me.
I can't answer those.
But after this, please,
if you have questions
about what I've said
today, afterwards we're
going to have a
little Q&A session.
So what I wanted to
sort of bring together
is my thoughts about
emotions and when
you're working on
these projects.
So for those that live
and breathe 10X concepts,
meaning ideas that improve
problems by 10 times,
I truly believe
that your emotions
can be your North Star.
So anxiety, for example--
it's not always a bad thing.
Medically, it increases
your blood flow.
It releases hormones
like adrenaline.
It allows your mind
to work on overdrive.
For those procrastinators
in the room--
I am one of them-- your
work can feel better
when you wait till
the last minute.
Sometimes that pressure to
produce just makes better work.
But for a lot of
people, anxiety is
felt because you
don't have a plan.
So I think it's
important to note
that you can't plan innovation.
You can have these
big ideas, and you
have an idea where
it's going to,
but there really is no concrete
roadmap for innovation.
I once heard the
creator of Radiolab,
which is by far
my favorite radio
show-- I absolutely
love that show.
And he's won great
awards for basically
changing the format of radio.
He said, "I don't think
change can be planned.
I think it's only
something that can
be recognized after the fact."
And I absolutely
agree with this.
And the two projects I
shared with you today,
I think it's absolutely--
we're obviously still working
on the self-driving car.
But we're definitely
feeling this.
So you can have a plan,
especially for the next couple
weeks, but expect that
it will change a lot.
Because there's a lot
you just don't know.
The real challenge is
to be OK with that,
and to recognize that
your anxiety is usually
a sign that you're either
going to figure something out,
you're about to get there, or
the plan is about to change.
It's one of the two.
So for those moments that you
experience fear with your work,
know that fear is usually
a sign that you're
working on something brand new.
And that's a pretty lucky
place to be as a designer.
This is a rare, rare
occasion, so be grateful.
But you may be a new
designer learning your craft.
That is also a scary place.
And you're trying things
for the first time.
Or you may be
working on something
like the self-driving car.
It kind of feels the same.
Either way, you're
diving into the unknown.
And you will learn from it.
If you're feeling
comfortable, chances
are you either found a
bit of clarity and maybe
a few answers, or maybe you've
relied on something safe
and maybe already done.
That's not necessarily
a bad thing.
But please make sure
that you're doing it
because it's a
better experience,
not because it's easier.
And this is my last
major point here.
If you are experiencing
a moment of joy,
those moments where
you're like, I freaking
did that-- and we've all kind
of had either little moments
of that, or big ones
where there was a launch,
or you just showed
up for a meeting,
and you were really actually
proud of that design--
take the time to celebrate.
More often, I see so
many designers run out
of drive and creativity
because they're pushing
and they're fighting to
get to those moments that
reveal answers.
And they just start to burn out.
And I really think
small celebrations
throughout your process will
save you from burning out,
especially when you're
working on a very
long-term innovative project
like the self-driving car.
So feel love for design.
That will keep you going.
Be grateful that you have
the power and privilege
to make something meaningful.
And that's it for me.
Any questions?
I'd love to answer
any questions I can.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
DIEGO: Hi, I'm Diego, and I'm
a designer and researcher.
I was wondering if
you could tell us--
and I don't know if you can--
how do you quickly validate
some of the assumptions
that you're working on?
It seems like there's a pretty
significant prototype you're
playing with, with the car and
the interface working together.
JENNY ARDEN: Yeah, so I'd
say that our project is
divided into two components.
So there's industrial design.
And luckily, with
building a car,
there is some
precedence to that.
And there's some
people actually here
that know about that
process way more than I do,
because I didn't
come from automotive.
So they're kind of roughly
following this process.
But like I was
kind of explaining,
they course-correct a lot.
And they are all willing to kind
of deal with change and deal
with limitations that
they're faced with.
So it's almost more of an
attitude than a process.
They have a process,
but they also
have the attitude
to accept change.
On the digital side, we
have two major components
that we're working on.
It's the phone app,
the control of the car.
And we have this kind of
crazy screen in the prototype.
It's long and
skinny, and it sits
about four feet from the eye.
That's the one that is
more difficult for us.
We can design a phone app pretty
easily to control the car.
But that UI and the
engineering interface
that I shared with you,
it's pretty gnarly.
So basically what we do is
we just try everything out.
Everything is a hypothesis.
And we get into the prototype.
If you don't experience
it firsthand,
if it's just at your
computer, you're
never going to
get a real answer.
So we really believe in
taking it out in the field
and experiencing it firsthand
and getting a gut check
with it.
And then obviously, the
next step after that
is testing with real users.
So we've identified
user groups that we
want to really get
their feedback from.
We put it in front of them
and get their insights.
And we just keep going
and going and going.
This is not sort of
a waterfall effect.
My researchers are next
to me every single day
testing things.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
You're a user experience
designer, correct?
I'd love to know more about the
experience you're aiming for.
Because it seems so broad,
and everyone in the video
is either-- not disabled.
Everyone's happy.
And everybody's
having a great time.
And I'm curious.
Are you striving for
collaboration and communication
between passengers?
I just am a little more
curious about the specifics
of that goal.
JENNY ARDEN: Yep, so I
agree, everyone in that video
did look very happy,
unnaturally so.
But they actually
were really happy.
It was a good day for us.
The experience, I'd say we have
different feelings about it
depending on when you're
thinking about the project
and how far along it is.
So when we release it
to the world, which
will happen one day, we're
just trying to get trust.
We just want people to feel
safe and really trust it.
And we will not launch anything
that isn't absolutely safe.
We have very, very high bars
for all of our safety metrics.
So safety, trust-- number one.
Friendly-- no scary robots.
That's really important to
us as a user experience team.
Further out, though,
the feeling that we have
is that we can actually change
some really interesting aspects
about society.
Think about it-- you get
your driver's license
as a rite of passage
when you're 16-ish.
What if that doesn't
exist anymore?
That's kind of crazy.
There's a fly over here.
So what is the new rite
of passage for driving?
There are lots of things
culturally in our DNA
about driving,
especially in California.
We care so much about driving.
How is this project
going to change that?
And those are the things that
we're thinking about a lot.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Have you done any explorations
of more nontraditional spaces
within the car,
thinking about it
not just as a place for seats,
but as a place for a desk,
as a place for an
exercise bike, as a place
to accomplish other goals while
you are being transported?
JENNY ARDEN: Absolutely.
So one of the questions I posed
was, what is the new driving?
If you're not driving,
you're doing something else.
So if you're doing something
else, what is that,
and how can the space
enable that other activity?
So could we enable working?
Could we enable conversations?
Maybe enable productivity,
or just relaxation-- you just
want to unplug and
sit back and relax.
As a user experience
team, these are definitely
the things we're thinking
about, and thinking
about how the interior
of the vehicle
itself can be
configured or changed.
Or we can design
something to really cater
toward one of those experiences.
AUDIENCE: Now that
you're spending
so much time in
self-driving cars,
would you say that it's
made driving in your car
or driving around
more or less fun?
JENNY ARDEN: So I
actually hate cars.
I'm going to be totally honest.
I'm a cyclist.
I don't like cars.
So it's funny that
I'm on this project.
But it's actually great, because
I believe in a different thing.
I believe that there's a
place for cars, especially
the joy riding when
you love vehicles
and you love the machinery
and the engineering.
There are plenty of people
on my team who are like that.
And I respect all
of their hobbies
and their passion for it.
But for me, I'd say
that I am already
someone who was kind
of on the other side.
In college, I was
in a major accident.
And I had post-traumatic
stress from it,
so I couldn't actually get
into a car for about a year.
I had to walk or ride my bike.
That's why I became
a cyclist, because I
was so terrified
to get into a car.
So I already, in my
depths of my being,
really feel that this
is a necessary thing.
OK, thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]